the Saudi foreign minister says
representatives from Sudan's warring
sides are in Jeddah it marks the first
talks between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces since
fighting erupted more than three weeks
ago
both sides said they would not negotiate
and end the conflict and would only
discuss a humanitarian truce hundreds of
people have been killed and thousands
injured in the conflict Russell Cedar
has more from Jeddah
we know that the talks are on the way in
in Jeddah and Saudi Arabian officials
and Americans are putting a tremendous
pressure on both parties to Agony On
City points the first one is to open up
a humanitarian Corridor for uh for for
cartoon and for its things
and the second one is to provide the
protection to the civilian facilities
including the hospitals the third one is
to secure a truce and also to build a
mechanism that will monitor these truths
and also keep accountable those who
violate that so these are what they want
to achieve here in Jeddah and it's
people familiar with the with the issues
and also some sources are saying that
there is a positivity around because of
some internal and external factors until
there's Dynamics out of Sudan as well
first there is a divement demonstration
in Sudan and second most fighting
companies now are realizing that they
will not be be an equipment for any of
them and if the world need one both
sides are going to lose
Eva Morgan has been following
developments on Saturday from the
Sudanese Capital Khartoum
it was relatively quiet especially when
you compare it to the previous 21 days
but over the past couple of hours we
were able to hear Heavy Artillery being
fired in the northern part of the
capital Khartoum in the city of bahri
specifically we can see plumes of smoke
rising from the center of Bahrain in
what's known as the industrial area in
that part of the capital Khartoum and
also in East Nile now residents of East
now say that there were artillery
strikes and airstrikes being launched by
the Sudanese Army against supposed rsf
positions in that area so when it was
relatively quiet in the afternoon now
the situation is completely different
around the vicinity of the presidential
Palace we can also hear Heavy Artillery
but it's not clear if it's the Sudanese
Army firing at the rapid support forces
who are inside the presidential Palace
or whether it's the rapid support forces
trying to counter attacks from the
Sudanese Army then there's also the city
of niana in in South Darfur there was
fighting between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army at around 4
pm local time that's around for 14 GMT
and that ended with according to
Residents with the Sudanese Army pushing
back the rapid support forces who were
trying to take over the capital so while
talks are ongoing in the city of Jeddah
in Saudi Arabia here in hartum fighting
is still very much ongoing between the
rapid support forces and the Sudanese
Army